il titolo di questa chiacchierata anche
però non compare sul video
eccolo qua
subito non è un titolo provocatorio
perché non possiamo non dirci africani e
secondo me la cosa più a nesta che
possiamo dire sulla nostra origine sulla
nostra diversità
siamo i discendenti di un piccolo gruppo
di africani che ha avuto la fortuna al
momento giusto di fare la cosa giusta
emigrare però appunto parlando di onestà
ci sono anche modi disonesti di
descrivere le nostre differenze e quello
classico è il modo razziale
io preferisco partire oggi dal
contributo significativo che ha dato il
nostro paese al razzismo scientifico il
famoso manifesto degli scienziati
razzisti o decalogo degli scienziati
razzisti è uscito nel 1938 in una
rivista
nel primo numero di una rivista che si
chiamava la difesa della razza e che
sostanzialmente ha costruito l'ambito
sociale all'interno del quale sono state
accettate dalla maggior parte dei nostri
concittadini le leggi razziali che
privavano dei diritti civili cittadini
italiani di razza ebraica questo un
documento che dal punto di vista della
comunicazione è fatto molto bene
comprende 10 slogan che vi ho riassunto
qua e un breve paragrafo di spiegazioni
e stato probabilmente dettato da
mussolini elaborato ad alcuni giovani
antropologi e poi firmato dallo stato
maggiore degli scienziati dell'epoca e
vi chiederete ma perché ci parli del
lavoro di questi scienziati scadenti ve
ne parlo perché gli ostacoli contro cui
si scontrano senza riuscire a risolverli
gli scienziati scadenti che firmano il
documento degli scienziati razzisti sono
gli stessi ostacoli contro cui si sono
scontrati senza riuscire a risolverli
tutti bravi scienziati che dal 700 fino
all'età del novecento hanno cercato di
continuare il catalogo delle razze umane
tutti quanti erano d'accordo sul fatto
che queste razze ci fossero ma quando si
trattava di farne una lista ognuno
faceva la propria lista e questa cosa si
vede anche in questo elenco
il punto numero uno dice che le razze
esistono e nel 1938 non era una
posizione scandalosa lo pensavano quasi
tutti è più interessante il punto 3
perché si dice la razza è un concetto
puramente biologico la razza nel sangue
o diremmo oggi la razza nel dna
c'era gente che diceva di no ma se la
razza e nel sangue se la razza è una
cosa che ereditiamo dei nostri genitori
e dobbiamo infallibilmente trasmettere
nostri figli allora sarà possibile
studiarla con i criteri della scienza
della biologia sarà possibile fare un
elenco delle razze o almeno di rea che
razza apparteniamo a noi
e qui casca l'asino perché al punto
numero 4 si dice che noi italiani siamo
ariani ariano è una parola che deriva
dalla linguistica vuol dire gente che
parla lingue indoeuropee e quindi siamo
in una vasta compagnia che parte dal
portogallo e con qualche eccezione per
esempio l'ungheria per esempio la
turchia arriva fino nel bengala due
righe più sotto punto numero 6 siamo
diventati i razzi italiana abbiamo perso
tutta questa grande compagnia allora
siamo italiani siamo in d'europei riga
numero 8 siamo diventati mediterranei
dell'europa occidentale
quindi siamo come gli spagnoli e
francesi ma non come i portoghesi che
come sapete non si affacciano sul
mediterraneo e alla diga numero 10 siamo
diventati europei quindi abbiamo ripreso
tutti quanti compresi gli ungheresi
abbiamo perso gli asiatici un pasticcio
come mai degli scienziati abbastanza
seri firmano un documento di questo
genere che è totalmente incoerente
bene io direi che la risposta è ancora
scritta qua e al punto numero 7
è tempo che gli italiani si proclamino
francamente razzisti quando stiamo
parlando dell'umanità limitarsi ad un
discorso biologico è difficile si
mescolano altre considerazioni e qui c'è
una considerazione politica che
riassunta mio parere in maniera mirabile
da questa famosa copertina in cui si
vede il programma politico che sottostà
da questo documento un gladio che separa
una statua classica
forse sono gli italiani forse sono gli
europei occidentali chi lo sa noi
comunque da quelli che non devono
contaminarli l'ebreo e l'africano bene
si può pensare quello che si vuole di
questo progetto politico io spero che
come me ne pensiate tutto il male
possibile
però io sono venuto a dirvi che dal
punto di vista strettamente biologico
nel 1938 era troppo tardi perché questo
progetto potesse avere successo
bisognava intervenire molto prima
bisognava intervenire 35.000 anni prima
perché 35.000 anni prima c'erano gli
europei da circa 30mila anni gli europei
non ci sono più sono rimasti solo gli
africani
e lo dico perché per 300.000 anni
l'europa è stata occupata da queste
creature questo naturalmente il modello
creato da due artisti olandesi l'uomo di
neanderthal un'umanità che è rimasta nel
nostro continente dieci volte più lungo
di quanto non ci siamo rimasti noi gli
africani come rovinando italiani erano
un po come noi erano un po diversi da
noi
vivevano di caccia mangiavano quasi solo
carne erano più grossini più bassi di
avevano una distribuzione che
comprendeva quasi tutta l'europa tra il
nord dove c'è la troppo freddo una buona
parte dell'asia e il loro cervello non
ci è rimasto perché cervelli non si
lizzano ma il loro cranio che vedete
sulla destra era grande quanto il nostro
e volte di più solo che come vedrete
mentre noi abbiamo una fonte verticale
il loro invece andava giù in forte
pendenza
le regioni frontali della corteccia
frontale che sono così importanti nei
nostri processi razionali né i
neandertaliani anno sviluppate di meno
mentre magari ci vedevano meglio perché
avevano una regione occipitale più
grande creature come un cranio come
quello di sinistra che il cranio di
tutti noi oggi con pagano in africa
200.000 anni fa
restano lì per circa 150 mila anni e poi
rapidamente si espandono in tutto il
pianeta e contemporaneamente le forme
umane arcaiche neanderthal in europa
lectus in ansia e probabilmente altre
che non conosciamo si attingono quindi
oggi siamo rimasti soltanto noi una sola
specie gli africani la fronte verticale
il mento che ne andata non aveva il
cranio poco sviluppato all'indietro
sono caratteristiche assolutamente
africane ben più della pelle nera o dei
capelli ricci e come ce li abbiamo tutti
quanti queste caratteristiche non
possiamo non dire che siamo tutti quanti
africani siamo tutti quanti africani ma
come siamo fatti al nostro interno e non
sono qui per dirvi che siamo tutti
uguali
biologicamente anzi al contrario siamo
tutti diversi
non solo siamo diversi ma guardando
queste facce in molti casi riusciamo a
piazzare la persona nel continente
giusto per lo meno ea volte anche con
maggior precisione quindi di cinque di
queste persone non vi dico da dove
vendono perchè tanto lo capite da soli
quella ragazza polinesiana se avesse
anche
un fiore tra i capelli se per caso il
suo aspetto non fosse sufficiente a
rivelare le sue origini ma ci sono delle
dei problemi per esempio la ragazza a
sinistra in alto alla pelle scura della
bra grosse tutti noi diremmo che
africana
no viene dall'asia viene dalle isole
andamane e quindi nell'idea che
l'umanità è fatta a pezzi diversi che ci
sono varie razze ognuna con le sue
caratteristiche dobbiamo starci un po
attenti ma forse per capirci meglio fare
due esempi che ci vengono dal mondo
naturale
questo che vedete uno scimpanzé e le
varie regioni colorate che rappresentano
le zone in cui vivono le quattro
sottospecie o razze di cinta 0 un
esperto di scimpanzé leggendo il dna di
queste scimmie di questi primati ne può
collocare con la massima sicurezza
ognuno nell'area giusta cioè può dire se
viene dalla zona gialla o azzurro o
verde o viola quindi questa è una specie
in cui ci sono delle razze del distinte
che si possono distinguere con i criteri
della scienza è questa qua che vedete è
un tonno riconoscere tutti quanti la
pinna gialla e la famosa varietà pinna
gialla del tonno questa è una specie
invece in cui la razza non esistono se
pescate un tono nell'atlantico non c'è
nessun modo anche studiando tutto il dna
di questo tonno di dire se proviene
dalla costa americana da quella europea
i toni sono delle bestie che se vogliono
raggiungono gli 80 km all'ora e
attraversano l'atlantico in
continuazione gli scimpanzé invece sono
molto stabili e quindi butto lì l'idea
che ci sono delle razze quando gli
individui sono molto ancorati al loro
luogo di nascita e invece non ci sono
quando si scambiano continuamente
incrociano tra di loro anche a grandi
distanze e allora noi siamo come gli
scimpanzè o siamo come i toni da questo
punto di vista il dibattito risale
addirittura al settecento e il primo a
fare un catalogo delle razze umane e
questo signore linneo svedese
l'inventore della tassonomia moderna il
quale a un certo punto propone che ci
siano quattro razze umane
4 perché quattro sono gli elementi della
filosofia greca classica aria acqua
terra e fuoco anche linneo come vedete
che pure era un bravo scienziato si
lascia confondere da considerazioni poco
pertinenti quando si tratta di parlare
delle nostre differenze col tema si
cimentano alcune delle più grandi stelle
della scienza del settecento e
dell'ottocento blumenberg che era un
illuminista tedesco propone un sistema
cinque razze e si inventa la parola
caucasico che vuol dire poi i più belli
secondo lui più belli sono i caucasici
siamo siamo noi europei e questo è più
vi è grande e nato mista ripropone che
ci siano tre razze e nel frattempo però
gli esploratori esplorano i viaggiatori
viaggiano portano a casa descrizioni di
sempre nuove forme umane che non si
riesce a ficcare dentro al catalogo
della razza esistenti e quindi questi
cataloghi si dilatano negli anni 30 per
l'esposizione universale di chicago
malvina reynolds una scultrice americana
v server in carico di fare delle
sculture che rappresentino le razze
umane che dopo un po di studio propone
103 figure che sono ancora in parte
conservati al museo di chicago nel
ventesimo secolo si arriva sino a
sistemi con 200 razze diverse
e naturalmente dire che ci sono 200
razze oppure dire che non si capisce
niente praticamente lo stesso infatti
qualcuno protesta
questo è un altro polo go americano
piano frank livingston e negli anni 60
pubblica questo articolo che si chiama
sulla non esistenza delle razze umane in
cui livingston dice io non sto dicendo
che non ci sono differenze nella nostra
specie
sto dicendo che queste differenze non
corrispondono ai pacchetti discreti che
materazzi
in altre parole gli umani non sono come
i telefonini che se sono samsung non
sono motorola e non sono nokia le nostre
differenze sono fatte di sfumature una
proposta molto radicale che incontra
delle difficoltà anche presso scienziati
bravi questo è un bravo scienziato si
chiama adobe jean ski è uno dei
fondatori della genetica e dowjones chi
riconosce che ci sono due piani un piano
biologico è un piano sociale di cui
tener conto
chi scrive che i nostri comuni diritti
umani derivano a non dal fatto che siano
biologicamente uguali ma dal fatto che
siamo tutti umani
però dopo jean si riafferma negli anni
settanta la fiducia che si possa un
giorno fa li catalogo delle razze lui
dice gli sviluppi tecnologici futuri ci
permetteranno finalmente di vedere quali
sole
ora la buona notizia che il futuro è
arrivato noi viviamo nel futuro e
possiamo fare delle cose che all'epoca
non si potevano farlo fino agli anni 70
si misuravano crani si misuravano misure
corporee e poi si cercava di
interpretarli oggi si legge il dna e
qualunque scienziato di fronte agli
stessi dati del dna arriva le stesse
conseguenze conclusioni il dna viene
spesso descritto con un lunghissimo
testo all'interno di ciascuna delle
nostre cellule e lo è in effetti è un
testo di cui conosciamo l'alfabeto le
quattro molecole alle quattro basi che
lo costituiscono
e in ogni cellula ce ne sono 6 miliardi
e mezzo e oggi è diventato tecnicamente
possibile leggere tutte queste basi
tutte queste lettere l'inter darvi
un'idea i promessi sposi sono lunghi
circa un milione di caratteri quindi
ogni nostra cellula contiene al suo
interno un libretto di istruzioni pari
circa 3.500 volumi dei promessi sposi
come faccio a maneggiare questo libretto
non è non l'abbiamo ancora capito però è
possibile leggerlo è possibile cercare
le differenze e cercando le differenze
si è visto che se confrontiamo europa
asia e africa
qui ho lasciato fuori altri continenti
per fare le cose più semplici quello 81
per cento vuol dire che l'ottanta per
cento delle differenze nel nostro dna
sono presenti in tutti i continenti sono
cosmopolite
io sono di gruppo sanguigno 0 e chi è di
gruppo sanguigno 0 può venire da
qualunque continente perché il gruppo
sanguigno 0 e dappertutto e lì forse
vedete che in europa c'è uno 0,06 per
cento è molto difficile essere
geneticamente europei e c'è un 1 per
cento in asia è molto difficile essere
geneticamente asiatici
c'è però un 7 per cento in africa
l'africa è diverso dagli altri
continenti
non solo perché contiene i fossili più
antichi dei nostri antenati ma perché
contiene anche un repertorio più vasto
delle nostre differenze genetiche
però quello 81 per cento in mezzo ci
spiega perché non è stato possibile
tagliare a fette il pianeta indicando le
varie razze nelle varie zone perché
abbiamo tutti le stesse cose in comune è
l'esempio più bello secondo me viene
dallo studio dei genomi completi del dna
completo di queste tre persone sono tre
biologi quello in mezzo jim watson lo
scopritore insieme a francis crick della
struttura a doppia elica del dna
craig venter è un coreano
si chiama kim sono stati eletti il loro
dna completamente e se li confrontati
non so se riuscite a leggere qua e
interessante quello che queste persone
hanno in comune a due a due
perché il 20 e watson sono chiaramente
due europei 2 americani di origine
europea e si vede ma hanno in comune
meno del loro dna di quanto ciascuno di
loro abbia in comune con kim
quindi se li volete mettere insieme
sulla base di tutto il loro dna o
mettete venter con kim e watson sta
fuori o watson con kim evento sta fuori
ma non potete mettere insieme watson ed
inter
questo non vuol dire naturalmente che
per ognuno di noi c'è un piccolo coreano
che il nostro gemello biologico vuol
dire semplicemente che siamo tutti così
diversi anche in questo teatro che tra
di noi tra due di noi si possono essere
differenze più grandi di quelle che ci
sono tra uno di noi è un coreano un
messicano è quello che volete voi
quindi non ci sono dei dati moderni che
si permettono di dire che siamo come gli
scimpanzè siano come i toni ci siamo
mossi moltissimo e negli ultimi tre
minuti che mi restano farò una cosa un
po spericolata di riassumere l'intera
storia dell'umanità in due diapositive
non fatelo a casa vostra un'operazione
pericolosa e quello che gli scienziati
chiamano un modello una visione
semplificata di come sono andate le cose
centomila anni fa stavamo in africa e
quei pallini colorati sono i nostri
antenati indicati con colori diversi
perché erano biologicamente diversi che
vita facevano questi nostri antenati non
se la passavano bene non potevano
produrre il cibo
l'agricoltura nasce 10.000 anni fa non
100 mila anni fa quindi andavano in giro
sottoposti ogni sorta di rischio di
carestie e senza mappe esplorato nel
territorio per quei 70 mila anni fa
circa li vedete che siano sparsi in giro
per l'africa e sono comparsi nuovi
colori a rappresentare il processo
naturale di mutazione che produce sempre
lentamente un po alla volta
tante nuove differenze biologiche alcuni
di loro che ho indicato in giallo in
verde sono arrivati in palestina quasi
non lo sanno non hanno mappe ma quando
passano in palestina intorno 60 mila
anni fa
succede una cosa molto importante perché
l'asia ha molte più risorse dell'africa
ed è praticamente spopolata c'è qualche
neanderthal mai neanderthal erano
persone perbene e soddisfazione
molto rapidamente e a questo punto
succede una cosa che charles darwin
aveva previsto pur senza conoscere
nessuno di questi dati
quando ci sono più risorse il numero di
bambini che raggiunge l'età della
riproduzione più grande e questi bambini
lasceranno dei figli che avranno a loro
volta una maggiore probabilità di
lasciare altri discendenti e così via
e quindi la popolazione che è uscita
dall asia cresce e va a colonizzare
tutta quanta la terra ma non solo tutti
gli africani sono un sottoinsieme degli
africani i gialli e verdi ed è per
questo che fuori dall'africa oggi
troviamo dei sottoinsiemi della
variabilità biologica africana
chiaramente saranno successe molte altre
cose ma se questo schema funziona come
io penso allora questo schema ci
permette di capire non solo i pochi dati
che vi ho presentato ma tanti altri
anche che non ho avuto modo di
presentarvi concludo con charles darwin
l'uomo il cui pensiero costituisce
tuttora a 150 anni di distanza la spina
dorsale della biologia contemporanea
darvi una differenza di molti suoi
contemporanei non propone un catalogo
razziale e anzi cerca di parlare
dell'uomo il meno possibile almeno del
suo libro fondamentale l'origine delle
specie tra un certo punto non ne può più
e lo dice mi riceve rate che gli esperti
hanno studiato l'umanità più di
qualunque altro animale ma tra gli
esperti cioè non tra i matti che pure si
sono occupati di questi problemi
scrivendo delle cose pazzesche ma tra
gli esperti non c'è nessun accordo sul
fatto che l'umanità si è costituita da
una sola razza oppure due o tre o
quattro come diceva kant che immanuel
kant il filosofo che anche lui si era
fatto il suo catalogo razziale oppure 5
come dice blumenberg oppure 6 7 8 15 20
22 60 63 qui soft air wing ci sta
dicendo
finché non ci mettiamo d'accordo sulla
definizione di questi gruppi all'interno
dell'umanità non potremo studiare
scientificamente io sono uno scienziato
e di queste cose non voglio occuparmi
grazie
[Applauso]